um what was the project working with
Harry Fraud light because Harry Fraud is
another one of those guys who
for whatever reason
he's got classic music and I still I
feel like he's still underappreciated
when we think of the best producers but
like you guys delivered one of my
favorite albums last year yeah I
appreciate that Harry is like amazing
man and real good guy man like uh
you know
he he he's seen the potential in me
early that's what really make me
appreciate him you know what I'm saying
for him to do a whole project with me
early when my you know I mean before
everybody was you know what I'm saying
for sure so uh
that was dope you know he actually had
me come out to his house out in uh the
Hamptons and I stayed out there for
about five days he's doing well yeah if
he's got a house in the Hamptons yeah
definitely I was out there for like five
days and we recorded the whole project
and [__] we actually sat there I picked
out he he had a bunch of Beats to the
side for me I picked out probably like
four and then we actually dug through
samples for the rest from scratch all
from scratch that's why it sounds so
beautiful because he's sitting there
digging like oh no that's the sample
right there you know I mean that was my
first time working with a producer like
that by collaborating collaborating like
that you know what I'm saying like
you're helping find a sample like like
yeah like yeah now this stuff yeah you
found I mean I mean yeah you helped make
the beat then you know because we just
heard I mean I just heard Rick Rubin say
he doesn't touch anything he doesn't
know how to sample he doesn't know how
to he's there for his taste and he's one
of the greatest producers of all time
right right right right but you know
what me being yeah yeah hell yeah so
like that [__] that [__] was a beautiful
beautiful
situation and it came out beautiful man
you know what I'm saying and then you
guys just got the features after because
there's some great features we went and
got the features after
um yeah Harry reached out and got Jim
and Wiz you know I'm saying I went and
got bed and Ranch that I do got a shout
out to whiz man because you'll always
see whisp still pop up on like
independent rap [__] always that's big
man and like where's his whiz like he's
like such a superstar where it's like
damn Wiz is on the 38 Special album
that's crazy I gotta hear what that
sounds like yeah that's fine man Shout
Out The Wiz did he did you obviously
he's up on what you're doing if he
decided to do it because he's not doing
anything I don't think you can pay whiz
to get on the record I take that back
you could definitely pay anybody to get
on the record if the bag's right but for
the most part thing if you see where's
jumping on something it's because he
wants to do it right yeah so he must be
you know tapped in locked in you guys
chop it up at all or was it more of a
hairy thing it was a hairy thing yeah
you know came out dope appreciate that
came out super dope um
now this year at least three projects
three joints how many songs is on this
new album
nine so I kind of like how you keep it
yeah manageable I'll be trying to tell
guys you don't got to give them too much
if I gave them 20 right you could do two
albums and even if I gave them 20 yeah
it's only gonna last the same amount of
time they they ain't gonna appreciate it
it's Gonna Last the same amount of time
what's good about your fans though is
that they consume projects right so I
think that like I agree with you eight
nine ten records is enough
right certain artists
to me it's the same thing with when I
think of scene when I see artists with
zero fans putting out albums
it's frustrating because I'm like yo
that's like one impression
you take that album and put out 10
singles if you don't have fans and then
let each one of those songs
equal a new impression you know what I
mean for you you have fans
they want your body and you're really
good at putting together bodies of work
not everybody so appreciate that who's
uh taking care of production on this one
you told me uh oh yeah so uh I gotta I
produced uh I only produced One joint on
this and uh I I went around damn man I
got Harry's on there okay I got a joint
with Harry uh I got a kid named Don
Carrera that I just
discovered fire and uh
[__] man
you gotta pardon me I've been working on
so much damn music bro you just said you
have like yeah
you know y'all got a part of me if uh
what about features on this one that's
dropping that's what's technically out
oh yeah so right now on this one I kept
at home team I got Ransom I got shayno I
got Fred the golf something rest in
peace now I'm saying and I got flea Lord
shout out to flea Lord man yeah I kept I
kept it all in-house kept it kept it
easy I like it man